c'est un véritable vent de panique qui
souffle sur la france depuis que la
semaine dernière l'italie a été touché
de plein fouet par une recrudescence du
coronavirus en italie le virus a fait 11
morts en suisse le premier cas de
contamination a lui aussi été déclaré
tandis qu'en chine le bilan s'élève à
plus de 2000 morts et l'information
vient de tomber il ya quelques minutes
deux nouveaux cas ont été confirmés en
france une panique qui se traduit en
pharmacie par l'achat massif de masques
de protection visant à limiter les
possibilités de contamination et ce sont
précisément ces masses qui sont
aujourd'hui en rupture de stock
c'est la raison pour laquelle olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé a
annoncé dimanche une commande massive de
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
masques de protection de type ffp2 grâce
à son système de filtration ces masques
peuvent empêcher les bactéries de
s'infiltrer dans les voies respiratoires
de ceux qui les portent
mais ne sont efficaces que trois heures
une commande massive qui peut inquiéter
mais qui n'est pas destiné à la
population mais bien aux professionnels
de santé qui pourraient se retrouver en
contact avec des patients contaminés
pour le moment la france est épargnée
par le virus mais beaucoup sont peu
optimistes sur son évolution alors qu'il
se trouve aux portes du pays des
précautions sanitaires extrêmes sont
plus que jamais attendu
alors donc dimanche dernier le ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand annoncé
commandes massives de plusieurs dizaines
de millions de masques de protection
ffp2 maintenant c'est devenu on a des
mecs spécialistes car moi je crois que
j'étais au bureau ce matin
ats afp un couteau que c'est un truc de
fou alors juste déjà merci allô docteur
éric choisi d'être avec nous merci
là on commence à tous être inquiet en
italie au wac c1 en france là ça arrive
on gagne aussi en chine celui qui en
sicile
il faut s'inquiéter ou pas il faut
s'inquiéter
le corps d'un virus continue son chemin
on vit pas dans une bulle
donc on aura probablement oui penser
qu'on va avoir une épidémie oui je sais
ça je peux pas vous dire on a deux
nouveaux cas aujourd'hui
ouais de nouveaux cas qui ont été
hospitalisés
on ne peut pas dire que on n'aura pas de
cas c'est impossible
donc il faut se préparer il faut vous
préparer
comment comment comment se prépare alors
comment on se prépare
d'une part il faut être conscient que ça
peut arriver ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose on a en france un
système de santé qui fonctionne bien
c'est là qu'on a demandé aux gens ne pas
venir aux urgences de pas se déplacer
d'appeler le 15 en a qui évite que les
gens se baladent un petit peu partout et
éventuellement s'ils sont porteurs du
virus qui le répandre un peu partout
donc quand il nous appelle on leur dit
bah écoute et voilà qu'est ce qui se
passe vous venez d'où vous avez quel
signe parce que non c'est bon c'est pas
bien de rire de moi bon c'est pas moi
les mois la semaine dernière j'étais
j'étais un peu pas bien je suis dit que
peut-être tchad et le coronavirus
vraiment les trucs sur alors les trucs
sur c'est la même chose que la grippe
c'est à dire la fièvre on a des
courbatures et on a des signes
respiratoires
à partir du moment où on a ces six mois
et qu'on revient une zone qui a infecté
on est considéré comme un cas possible
d'accord lorsqu'on est un cas possible
il faut faire un prélèvement c'est un
petit écouvillon nage dans son va avoir
un examen qui dira il ya le virus ya pas
le virus
l'accord final pas le virus tant mieux
vous rentrez chez vous vous avez la
grippe
si elle verus on est là bas est si voilà
exactement d'accord c'est ça va assez
oui par m que ces signaux l'aca au mois
de mars ça peut être la simple grippe ou
pas du tout et bien évidemment la grippe
au mois de mars et que décembre quand
elle était mineure
on peut avoir aujourd'hui vous pouvez
attraper la grippe si vous n'avez jamais
été en chine en italie enfin lombardie
où vous avez la grippe d'accord alors on
va parler aussi des masses parce que il
ya c'est n'importe quoi sur les mâts sur
internet il ya des trucs assez fou des
sites proposent des masques à des prix
hallucinants
on trouve des masses par exemple alors
est ce sp2 alors celui-là c'est le plus
gros c'est le blanc c'est celui qui nous
protège canard alors celle là c'est le
bec de canard c'est ça cf p 2 celui qui
nous protège sur celui qui protège les
personnels de santé
d'accord donc nous aussi on peut
l'acheter celui-là dire une banane alors
on pouvait l'acheter mais mais commence
au lendemain comme ça avec des cannes à
bec de canard
là je suis protégé la petite reprendra
quant au très bien et donc je suis là
alors celui-là on se protège et protège
les autres alors on se protège
effectivement et bien évidemment nous
protège les autres puisque cet instinct
masque hermétique
ouais ok j'avoue là emanuel serge passé
dit quoi donc 180 euros on a eu en à la
violence à 180 euros
on en a vus à 205 euros non mais ce que
ce que vous voyez ce que vous voyez là à
ces prix là c'est soit des fêtes news
d'accord soit c'est le prix de la boîte
ah oui d'accord un temps viendra à toi
tu es là commun alors la boîte en prie
hospitalier il faut compter à peu près
entre 2 et 6 euros le masque d'accord
donc c'est les boîtes de salles par jour
on doit se changer de masse tous les
jours alors évidemment c'est les masques
qui ont une durée de vie limitée
ainsi vous l'aviez bien mis vous auriez
vu que en respirant avec il a tendance à
ce qu'aulas b comme ça adapté au bout
d'un moment vous avez delà de la bu et
enfin 2 et
évidemment il faut le changer d'accord
alors après on a la vue on regarde et on
en a vu un lot de dix masques sp1
regardez regardez bien à 9999 euros dans
mon croyez que c'est une blague
on voit tous à des mecs qui vont des ddd
des conneries et c'est vrai que en ce
moment on a très très peur celui-là est
ce qui sert à quelque chose je suis
alors celui là il sert à une chose très
claire c'est éviter d'envoyer des
postillons
ah d'accord donc ce masque là c'est le
masque qu'on a donné à la personne
d'isabelle saint-pascal âge à la mer si
vous prenez le site pour mamie la crise
elles selon canal coronavirus elle parle
une fois frère alors là c'est parce que
c'est un parapluie mais est donc oui
donc voilà donc celui-là c'est celui-là
c'est un masque ce qu'on appelle le
masque chirurgical 1 c'est un match
qu'il faut pas faire ça vaut 60 centimes
normalement je parle en tarifs
hospitaliers 1
alors on va peut-être retrouver un euro
cinquante en pharmacie ou deux roues je
sais pas mais ça ce sont des masques qui
sert uniquement à éviter de postillonner
donc c'est le masque qu'on va mettre aux
patients d'accord on va lui dire vous
mettez cela ce que là et puis comme ça
vous postillonner pas et l'autre les
sceptiques le fsp 2 celui-là le bec de
canard
c'est le masque que porteront les
soignants c'est celui-là alors est ce
qu'on nous dit tout dans les médias sur
le coronavirus ou est-ce qu'on nous
cache des choses pour pas voilà pourquoi
nous d'un fellah qui affolée et de
vannes a évidemment qu'on dit tout dit
ou vraiment mais bien sûr ah oui bah
évidemment oui j le dr ya un décalage
quand même moi je sais que
personnellement je cherche des masques
il ya plein de gens dans les pharmacies
la seconde veut acheter des masques et
le personnel de santé nous dit mais les
masses et pour postillonner mais la
population commence à être vraiment
inquiète alors oui ou non les yeux dans
les yeux
est ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui porter un
masque dans l'hérault marié de france
pourquoi vous voulez acheter des mains
sont protégés par du virus y protéger de
coire
des propagateurs qui pourra avoir le
virus mais en france le système il il
est pas mal fait je veux dire à partir
du moment où on revient d'une région
dans laquelle le virus sévit
on vous demande de rester chez vous donc
vous n'avez aucune raison de mettre un
masque la mafia en italie on n'a pas
d'abord on n'a pas du tout le même
système de santé et on est allé on est
dans une zone où le virus est est en
pleine activité
c'est pas le cas en france j'ai un truc
de magna un match de foot à lyon il ya
3000 italiens soient mes supporters
italiens qui vont venir à lyon qu'est ce
qu'on fait et bien mettez des masques
dans les tribunes pour les choses
l'ancien ministre de la santé douste
blazy a dit cela dit ce matin c'est à il
faut à l'intérieur du match est très
grave ils vont être 3010 vont être collé
aujourd'hui d'y éviter de vous toucher
de vous coller et oui un vrai risque est
mauvaise c'est des cons un médecin à la
télé à la télé mais avait l'air de dire
que écouter les entrées mais je dis pas
que c'est une monnaie garder des genres
dans un bateau pas moins une jolie et je
dis qu'il faut être logique
il faut être logique si un risque je
vous dit mettez un masque si ya pas de
risque je vous dit mettez pas de masque
vous vous baladez dans les rues de paris
vous n'avez pas de risque donc pourquoi
acheter un masque d'aller dépenser de
l'argent pour rien parce qu'en plus
moi je peux vous le donner en partant du
principe que je veux ça veut dire aussi
qu'on partait du principe que les gens
sont responsables les bons citoyens et
que quand on va leur dire qu'un vous
revenez d'un pays à peu près à risque
vous restez chez vous 14 jours devant le
fait que va lui falloir le riz le luxe
de rester 14 ans ont travaillé et
confiné chez soi avant de venir vous
frottez vos collègues à vos amis mais
alors que salomon tous alors pas
généreuse alors il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui
et là on a en fait on n'a pas le choix
si vous emmenez vos enfants vous revenez
aux enfants étaient chez leur grand-mère
en italie vous arriver aujourd'hui à la
crèche ou à l'école
1 on vous demande où vos enfants ont été
en vacances vous dites ils ont été en
italie ça on vous dit ben vous reprenez
votre enfant vous rentrez choix là c'est
bon mais de l'école doit aussi lundi on
avait régné les rentrées déjà depuis
jean-pierre il avait un mail de tf1 il
ya des gens qui disent que c'est pas
grave ça coronavirus et des gens qui
nous disent que c'est très grave parce
que c'est grave parce que c'est pas
grave si on l'attrapé ce qu'on doit pas
paniquer ou on est en race raoult ça
passe ça ce que ça se soit bien c'est
alors pour vous qui êtes en bonne santé
je l'espère ça va je gagne c'est pas
grave je suis ce qu'on appelle une force
de la nature
dans ce cas là c'est comme si vous
attrapez la grippe a pascoe par contre
pour moi qui est parfois un petit peu de
mal à respirer en série oui ça c'est un
club et donc ouais et alors pour moi ça
peut effet moi je suis très inquiet pour
les médecins et bien moi aussi ballon
mais sans rigoler on n'est pas en chine
le médecin chinois docteur vous êtes
vous ne soyez venu me voir parce que
j'ai très inquiet pour vous je suis très
inquiet pour les médecins non mais
franchement
et voilà mon père est médecin également
way et c'est vrai qu'il a une santé voit
là bas que voilà il ya un vide un peu
voilà il n'est pas il n'est pas très
âgée mais quand même
voilà et ben c'est vrai que je me dis
l'ipo est confronté lui ça peut être
grave pour pour lui mine de rien ça peut
être grave toutes les personnes
personnes vulnérables à qu'elles soient
âgées qu'elles aient des pathologies
kronenbourg et de diabète problèmes
cardiaques problèmes respiratoires
évidemment quand elle attrape un virus
pour lequel on a quand même malgré tout
pas de traitement bien sûr ça on n'a pas
tellement c'est ça qui s'adresse
traitement quand on attrape un virus
évidemment oui on a beaucoup plus de
chances que ce soit grave que si vous
avez 20 ans vous êtes une force de la
nature et
vous avez aucune pathologie j'ai une
patate mans mais voilà donc c'est vrai
qu'en fait c'est comme un peu comme la
grippe c'est ce que j'espère que si vous
êtes en bonne santé ils n'ont rien eh
ben ça sera soigné assez facilement et
même une grippe sur une personne en
mauvaise santé
ce week-end les proportions soit passer
importante moi là bas merci de couleurs
d'abord
[Applaudissements]